Canadá cierra uno de los capítulos más
oscuros de su historia reciente el
segundo de los dos sospechosos del
apuñalamiento masivo que el fin de
semana cobro 10 vidas está muerto mal
sanderson falleció luego de ser detenido
al norte del país tras una fuga de más
de tres días circulaba a más de 150
kilómetros por hora por una autopista
cuando fue finalmente alcanzado por la
policía
la policía rodeó el vehículo
confirmó que era él
lo arrestó se encontró un cuchillo en la
escenario Poco después entró en
dificultad médica llamó el servicio de
emergencias
fue llevado al hospital donde lo
declararon muerto
las circunstancias concretas del
fallecimiento serán determinadas por la
autopsia su hermano demien también
sospechoso de la masacre ya había sido
encontrado muerto el lunes la policía
investiga si fue asesinado por miles
pues presentaba lesiones causadas por
otra persona ambos eran los Únicos
señalados del hecho de violencia que
dejó 10 muertos y 18 heridos en una
reserva indígena de saskatchewan al
norte del país el pasado domingo los
familiares de los fallecidos aún no dan
crédito ha ocurrido
la situación que ocurrió no debería
ocurrirle a nadie en absoluto
me siento observo y Escucho y veo estas
cosas en la televisión
cómo le pasó esto a nuestra familia
porque sucedió no tenemos respuestas
9 de los fallecidos vivían en la reserva
el décimo era vecino de un pueblo
cercano tres de los heridos permanecen
en estado crítico con los dos
sospechosos muertos queda por resolver
qué motivó a un preso en libertad
condicional y a su hermano a
supuestamente cometer esta matanza